EDUARDO: I want to
apologize about something,
but I will leave
that until the panel.
And you can ask me why I was,
why I am apologizing now.
But anyway.
So hello.
My name is Eduardo.
And I want to start
with your help.
I know some of you
are very introverted
and will not want
to participate.
But just for one second,
everybody raised your hands.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Everyone, keep it up.
Keep it up.
Only one hand, so sorry.
Only one hand.
Don't cheat.
Yeah.
Thank you.
All right.
So if you are sure that--
let's do the first block.
If you're sure that you can
protect against XSS-- you
what is XSS.
[INAUDIBLE] explained it--
please lower your hands.
All right.
If you think you can
protect against CSRF--
you know what is CSRF.
Dean just talked about it--
please lower your hands.
No, I mean only lower it
if you know XSS and CSRF.
So anyway.
All right.
Anyway.
What about Mixed Content?
Lower it if you know
about Mixed Content.
OK.
What about Timing?
Timing attacks in
web applications?
No?
OK.
Anyone know about Direct
Object Reference bugs,
like Authorization Bypasses?
Info leaks and stuff like that?
Hash Extension bugs?
OK.
Maybe.
Let's do it backwards.
Lower your hands.
Anyone that knows how to do
Caching, use Caching correctly
for security purposes, like not
put the wrong Cache in headers.
Come on.
One person.
All right.
Maybe there's someone in
the other room as well.
Yeah.
Maybe all of-- if you are in the
other room-- no, I'm kidding.
Don't do that.
Anyway.
So web security vulnerabilities
are, well quite a lot.
[INAUDIBLE] already suggested
almost the same thing
I just did.
He was asking, oh,
so tell me whenever
there are security
vulnerabilities.
And you were coming out
with plenty of them.
Anyone didn't know about
one of the vulnerabilities
that she talked about
or that someone shouted?
So every one of you knew
all of the vulnerabilities
that were mentioned?
All right.
So knowing how to prevent them,
it's actually quite tricky.
Not in all cases,
it's trivial to know
exactly what you have to do.
So for XSS, you have
to know about Escaping,
about the right
type of Escaping.
We have talks about,
there is Escaping.
There is the right
type of Escaping.
But in the wrong order, and
then you introduce a bug.
For CSRF, there might
be CSRF token sent.
But then they are not
enforced in one case,
in the one case
that you need it.
There is Authentication
Bypass blocks,
and they are just forgotten
to have it in one place.
Generally speaking,
we have noticed,
or we reached the
conclusion that even
if you want to do
things safe, even if you
know about the bugs,
it's very likely
that you will
introduce them anyway.
We also notice that,
even if you don't know,
you are likely to
introduce them.
So if you care about
security, if you
don't care about
security, both ways,
you're going to introduce, in
one case, very complex bugs,
in the other case,
very simple bugs.
Maybe you don't know anything.
You will introduce more bugs.
But end of the day,
you're going to have
more than enough to have
an unsafe web application.
So as far [INAUDIBLE]
mentioned, I
work in the product
security team.
In the product
security response team.
And what my team does is,
whenever someone finds a bug,
like the ones that Tim
Willis just talked about,
we go, and we're with
the product team.
And we work with
them to make sure
that it never happens again.
So that means, make sure
that if a bug happened now,
we would try to look for
similar bugs around it.
We try to see what is
the real root cause.
And then, we make it
so that doesn't happen.
As we tried to do this
in the past couple years,
we concluded that we
cannot trust humans.
So humans are going
to make mistakes.
And we're all human.
So we all make mistakes.
And developers have to be
humans because otherwise we
have Terminator and
stuff like that.
So we came up with these that,
what the developer has to know
about security to be able to
develop secure applications is
what is in this slide and
that's-- in these slides.
And that's a wide slide.
And this is not all my slides.
But this is the first slide.
So if that's what
a web developer has
to offer security,
then how can they
develop web secure
web applications?
How do we have secure
So what we ended up
doing is that we are now
expecting that every security
bug is the frameworks fault.
That means that if you're
using a framework and framework
doesn't prevent you from
introducing XSS bugs,
then the framework is not
as complete as it should be.
And then, we should
implement, we
should implement something
in the framework that
prevent a bug from
being ever introduced.
That's why, that why the talk
is called Vulnerabilities
Should Not Compile.
Because it means that we should
make possible that a CSRF bug
can be launched into production.
We should not be possible that
an info leak or [INAUDIBLE]
Reference or whatever should
be launched into production.
What this talk is going to be
about is about several ways
that we have been
doing it in Google.
Or if we have not been doing it
in Google, what we are planning
to do in Google to prevent
this type of security
vulnerabilities.
Don't consider that the things
that we're going to talk,
about that I'm going to talk
about, but not all of them
are feasible for all
web applications.
So some of the things
might not make sense
for someone that is
developing a game.
Some of the things
might not makes sense
for someone that is developing
a bank application, for example.
Someone that has nothing to
do with a specific subset
of the [INAUDIBLE].
But still, the general principle
is the same, roughly speaking.
If I do my job right, then
by the end of the talk,
you will be able to eat, to
sleep, and code without having
to think about patching
a security bug.
So you're going to be able
to, if someone ever tells you,
we have to patch this XSS.
We have to patch this whatever.
Hopefully, the first thought
that will come to your mind
will be, no.
That's not how you fix this bug.
Let's see if this works.
Nope.
Oh, it worked.
So let's take one step
back and figure out
why we should even
care about this.
So why security is important.
This is super, super fast.
And I just want to mention
it for two reasons.
So because of your face,
because of your reputation
is in the line, because if
you have a security bug,
you are in the news
as Tim just mentioned.
Then, it is your brand,
your product, your website,
the one that is
being talked about.
The second reason is your money.
So if you are
marketing agency that
is making business with another
website, with another company,
and that company gets
hacked because of you,
you are not going to get
that business anymore.
If they talk with
each other, they
are most likely
not going to-- you
are going to have
a bad name overall.
And the most important
reason is because it's
your responsibility.
If you have users,
your users trust you.
And if your users trust you,
you have some responsibility
to them to be able
to protect them
against any type
of vulnerability
that you are meant
to protect them.
So I'm going to assume
that [INAUDIBLE].
So I'm going to
assume that all of you
want to do the right thing.
All of you want to know
how to do this correctly,
that you want to protect
the users and so on.
So the question is, what
is the right thing to do.
I just told you what I think
what is the right thing to do.
But let's see if
that's really the case.
So where do these
bugs come from?
So that's the right
question, right?
It's like, where
these vulnerabilities
are coming from.
Why do they exist
in the first place?
And the reason is, or
at least the reason
that we see is because
the services grow
bigger and more complex.
And by that I mean,
at some point,
you're going to have a website
that is moderately successful.
That is going to have
several users or many users.
And eventually,
you're going to have
more people that work on it.
And it's not just you.
Now, it's you and other people.
Now, eventually, you're
going to be talking
with other services
and other websites.
And eventually,
those other website
will want to talk
to you in some API.
Or you're going to be able to
use APIs of other sites like,
I don't know, Facebook or
Twitter or Google+ or whatever.
And eventually, all
of these becomes
just a huge complex
mix, completely mess.
So how do we look
at complex systems.
There is very popular
example of no one
really knows where
a pencil comes from.
It's very simple, but no one
knows every single component
where it comes from, the
paint, to lead, the eraser,
and everything.
What about an application
like I don't know, fancy.com.
Do you guys think that
there is one engineer
in the company that knows
how every single line of code
or that understands all
the complexities around it?
Like the Sandbox environments,
all the third party
dependencies that they have.
Maybe, there someone there is.
But it's more
likely there isn't.
So the way that developers
and anyone really
can cope with these complexities
that they just simply,
or we just simply see
it as a simple process.
So we just see it
like, OK, this is
what I expect to happen
in this scenario.
And we create a
very specific set
of schemas that-- or
patterns in our brain
of how things happen
in the general sense.
So we will be remembering, oh,
yeah, so this is probably--
this probably works in this way.
This probably works
in this other way.
And in some cases, it
works because the framework
makes it work like that.
And some other cases, it
doesn't work like that.
So I'm going to go through
five examples of when
the assumptions and the way
that you expect things to work
don't work quite like that.
That's the reason where--
that's a place where
security vulnerabilities,
in most cases, come from.
When you expect things to
work one way and they actually
they work a different way.
So the first one is XSS.
We talked about XSS a lot.
HTML5 probably the most
popular bug that any one of you
are going to
interact with is XSS.
This is an example of an XSS.
So it's hello.
This is PHP.
I'm sorry about that.
And it says hello and
then the variable name.
That's the user.
And you as a developer,
you or someone
who is writing this code
expect that to write the users
name not HTML.
When you wrote this code
or whenever that person
wrote this code, they
literally did not
expect that to be HTML, right?
So the right question to ask
is, why will it even be HTML.
Why shouldn't it
just be a string?
Because that's what
you expect, right?
This syntax is meant to inject
variables, not-- I mean,
it's meant [INAUDIBLE]
HTML as well.
But in most cases,
it's just going
to be used to inject variables.
All right.
Next example.
Authorization and CSRF.
So this is a very simple request
of a fake bank application.
And the fake bank
application, you just--
the only thing you want to
do, the thing that you want
this endpoint to do is
to transfer the amount
from from to to in that amount.
And if it fails, then
you send a error.
If it doesn't failed, then
you send a success response.
So that sounds ideal.
That will be the best type of
code that you could ever write.
It's super simple,
super compact.
These POST requests, the only
thing it does is call that API.
And that's it.
That's a code that you write.
That the code that
you want to write.
That's the code that does
what you actually want.
You don't actually want
to know about CSRF,
and how to generate
these tokens,
and how to authenticate if user
is allowed to do this or that.
That's not really what this do
POST request is meant to do.
This is just meant to do
this one very simple thing.
And you're going
to do it like that.
Another example, which
is very similar to XSS,
in the source, in the
reason where it comes from,
is that you want to have a
very simple SQL query that
says SELECT a star FROM
Product WHERE sku is equal to,
and some interpolate of
the string of called sku.
And this is short, and
simple, and readable.
If anyone looks
at the code, they
know what this code
is supposed to do.
Unfortunately, that will
narrow the SQL injection.
If you just put the
single code there,
you can do whatever you want.
But that's short, and that's
simple, and that's readable.
And that's vulnerable
to SQL injection.
You just want to make
things work nicely, right?
There are still other examples.
One of them is authentication.
The case for authentication
is a little bit tricky.
So you're going to log in.
And the only thing
you want is the user
to be able-- you just want
to authenticate the user.
You don't really want
to do anything else.
You just want to
know who the user is.
That's your goal when you
[INAUDIBLE] authentication.
And the first thing that
comes to mind to most people
when they think authentication
is a user name and a password.
That's normal, right?
So then you have to deal
with account recovery.
So you're going to do email, or
questions, or for enterprises.
How are they going to--
current enterprise, where
the company is going to recover
their corporate account.
If you have [INAUDIBLE]
/google, for example,
then how is Google going
to recover that account?
Like you cannot use
with secret questions,
because then an
ex-employee can recover it.
You cannot use an email, because
then the email can be changed.
So how do you deal
with those situations?
Recovery of use.
So how do you deal
with brute forcing?
How do you deal
with people brute
forcing their way
into an account.
We all know Twitter
has this problem.
That if you have two-tier,
one-layer handle,
everyone wants to get
into that account.
Hijacking.
How you deal with
someone hijacks account,
and then the real user
wants to get it back?
How do you deal with that?
You have to deal with some way?
How do you use social
engineering your own employees,
or employees [INAUDIBLE] users
to get their account back.
How would you deal
with password reuse?
How many times in the last
year password databases
have been leaked.
So that has been Adobe,
LinkedIn, several times.
Monitor hijackings.
You have to monitor
whenever that happens.
You're going to make
something in there.
You have to store your passwords
in some strong salted KDF
with maybe some key
that is [INAUDIBLE],
and then you have to
deal with performance
and making sure that
it happens correctly.
And that if you lose a key and
there's some cause of failure,
you're able to
recover gracefully
without having to depend on the
key being in the wrong place.
How to deal with
password managers.
If you are going to enforce
a minimum password strength,
then how are you going
to deal with that?
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
Before you go on, I don't really
know what Salt, what was that?
EDUARDO VELA NAVA:
You don't have to.
That's a trick.
AUDIENCE: What if I want to?
EDUARDO VELA NAVA: We
can follow up offline.
AUDIENCE: May I
talk to you after?
EDUARDO VELA NAVA: Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: Appreciate that.
EDUARDO VELA NAVA: So there
is more things, as I said.
Some users may want to know
about photo authentication.
Some people might want to
the detect suspicious actions
and then block their accounts.
Some people might want
to be able to deal
with [INAUDIBLE] authentication.
How to deal with a password in
a phone and then in a website.
With passwords, I think
I mentioned this briefly
before, you're going to
enforce a minimum strength.
You're going to protect
against brute forcing,
online brute forcing.
Putting captcha isn't going
to be enough, of course,
because then people that
want to get into account
are going to want
to have a captcha.
Are you going to put
a strength meter?
You're going to put
strength meter, how
are you going to
measure the strength.
I don't want to continue.
There is one more thing,
third party libraries.
And this is not all the
things about the security.
These are just five things
that I happened to choose,
because the diagram
have five balls,
and I wanted to put five things.
So for third party
libraries, you
have to read all
documentation and looking
for all dangerous functionality
and unsafe configurations.
So if you are going to
be using an XML parser,
you have to know about
XML external entities
and about [INAUDIBLE]
attacks and stuff like that.
You have to know
about if your media
player is downloading products.
If you're SVG does foreign
resolution of objects,
and then that allows itself
to load another other XML
file within you
SVG file, and then
load some internal
research in your page.
Or DOM.js, for
example, that was nice.
Some people were DOM.js,
which is an old thing
to load the scripts
from other page,
and that ended passing
remote [INAUDIBLE] execution,
because that's how it works.
You also have to
monitor CVEs, and change
logs, announce lists to
be able to know whenever
the thing has a security bar.
You have pull out
the deploy and fix.
You have to, once the
software goes out of life, how
are you going to deal with that?
If the new versions are
not compatible anymore,
if they have an API change,
what are going to do?
So all these things
seem super complicated,
and you just want to
do a simple thing.
You just wanted to
have a website that
shows videos to their friends.
And then you had to have
some video converters.
And then you have to
do authentication.
And then XSS, and authorization,
and CSRF, and SQL injection.
And how do you deal with that?
What is the right thing?
So the right thing is a blender.
This is not a
framework before anyone
thinks I'm selling
you a framework.
The reason I
mention a blender is
because it is an example of
something that all of you know,
I hope.
Something very special about it.
So it is a machine
that has motor
that turns super fast
and very strongly,
about 500 revolutions
per second.
And has super sharp
blade in it that
can destroy bones and do
all sort of scary things.
And somehow we were able
to put it in such a form
that it's relatively
safe to use.
There's reasonable not so
reasonable circumstances.
So just to share a story.
My wife was telling me that
she put a spoon inside one
of these blenders,
and it was OK.
I was like, yeah, that's right.
It should be OK.
So the blender has several
security mechanisms
to prevent them from
being a problem,
even if they are misuses.
If there is a warning
in the manual that
says, do not, under
any circumstances,
turn the know three
times and then
press the button five times.
Because in that
situation, then the blade
is going to go out spinning
and hit you in the eye.
That's not how it
works, except that's
how it works for several
web framers and platforms.
Like oh yeah, by the way, you
shouldn't do this in this way,
because if you do it then--
that's obviously vulnerable.
A blender is meant to
be safe against someone
that has seen someone use it
once, and can continue use it
without having to care
exactly about how it works.
It knows what is dangerous.
It knows there is a blade.
You know not to put
your hands inside.
And if you put
your hand inside, I
looked into-- I looked online.
Most people recover their hands.
Anyway, we shouldn't go there.
So maybe the right
thing to do is
to let developers
do what they need,
and then just fix these problems
in the framework ourselves.
And I'm going to explain
very quickly what this means.
So for example, for XSS, if a
user has a template like this,
and user_id is a
string, then it needs
to be URL sanitized
first, then URL escaped,
and then HTML escaped.
That's obviously right.
That's always right.
The framework can know this.
The framework
knows that the user
is about to write something
into that specific place.
It knows that this one only
requires HTML escaping.
It knows what escaping,
what order, in what case.
The framework knows.
It knows the context.
It knows HTML.
So it can just do it, right?
In this case, in name string,
it requires HTML escaping.
But what if name is
allowed to be HTML.
How do you deal with that.?
Well, then you can do
something like SafeHtml,
a new type that is
not just a string.
It's a string that has a
special meaning and that
is special for allowing
itself to be rendered as HTML.
And the framework
can recognize that,
oh this is not the SafeHtml.
Let's render it the SafeHtml
right on the string.
The framework knows that.
And the developer
that is writing
code that is putting this code
that it is, OK, this is HTML
will be safe.
Worst case scenario, you might
end up not escaping something,
but then you're going to note is
that does not escape correctly.
You're going to fix it.
You're not going to
cause security bug.
This gets a little
bit more complicated.
So Google Analytics,
for example,
gives you a script tag that you
have to put in your website.
So this is very similar to
what I mentioned before.
So if you have to put a
specific type of script up,
then the templating system can
detect that [INAUDIBLE] HTML
[INAUDIBLE], and then is
going to inject it like that.
And then the developer
doesn't really
have to think about, right?
They just have to
mark the things that
are meant to be HTML as HTML.
And if they are
not HTML, they are
going to be rendered
safely, so it works.
So you can store the HTML
as safe in databases.
You can do whatever you want.
You can make sure that your
apps are in XSS by default.
And this works for
client side applications
or for server side applications.
Another example is
authorization checks.
So you have four different
end points, web end points.
And you want these
web end points
to all have
authorization checks.
And what you have to
do usually, not always,
but you usually
have to do is you
have to put different
authorization
checks in different places.
So where should you put it?
Should you put it in here?
Or here?
Here?
In all of them?
Or in the top four?
I think the answer is pretty
obvious that you probably
want to put it as close
as possible to the data.
This is called usually row
level security, row level
authorization.
And if you put it this
way, it's more likely--
it's only one place that
you have to do the security,
that you have to program
any security output checks.
And if you do it right only
once, then you are safe.
If you do it wrong in
any of these four places,
then you are not safe.
These are things framework
can help you with.
Authentication.
There are two ways of
doing authentication.
Verify their identity--
if you trust your users
to have one of these
four accounts, or any
of the other ones, using
OpenID Connect or whatever.
Or you can do your own.
Maybe the framework
should provide something
to allow you to
do it by yourself.
And they should be able to
manage all the questions
that I asked before.
Or if you don't want
to do it yourself,
which is a reasonable thing
to do, do not do it yourself,
then you can just trust
one of the [INAUDIBLE]
providers to do it for you.
Libraries is the last one,
and I think it's interesting.
So if you have a
service that you
trust it to take a
screenshot of a website,
the only thing you want it to
do is to go take a screen shot,
and then give you the data log.
However, whatever you allow
of third party library,
it has this ambient authority
of access to everything.
So it runs as you.
It can [INAUDIBLE]
your source code.
It can read your keys and
connect to your databases.
It can do whatever it wants.
If you sandbox it, then
the only thing it can do
is connect through
HTTP to this service,
get the data ratings back, run
the rates, take a screenshot,
and then send you back the
screenshot as an image.
Same thing for the
compression functions.
For the compression
functions that need access
to the internet, it just
needs access to one directory.
It reads the directory.
It reads the compressed file.
It outputs [INAUDIBLE] and
then gives it back to you.
You can even do this for
encryption and key management.
You can OK.
You have access to this-- the
only thing you have access
is to this specific keystore.
Whenever someone access the
keystore, it lifts a log,
and then you can't
encrypt the data.
If someone finds a lock
in any of these things,
then they only get access
to one thing, right?
Then only get access to take
more screenshots, whatever.
They only get access to
decompressing more files.
Decompress away.
Bare with me for a second.
That's a pun.
So imagine that you
can write secure code.
You can write secure
web applications
without having to think
about security in general.
That you trust your framework
to do everything for you.
You might think that
I'm going crazy,
because there's no framework
that does this for you.
And you're kind of right.
So what we're doing, and we
are doing it starting today,
is that I want you by
the end of this talk,
to think about the
last security block
that you had to deal with.
It might in XSS.
It might be CSRF.
It might be whatever.
And I want you to send an
email to your framework
to whoever, whatever
framework you use.
And I want you to tell them
that they should fix it,
that they are responsible
for fixing it.
And if you want to
go one step ahead,
you can actually write
the code that does it,
and then send them the code.
Or you probably want to discuss
with them first and figure out
the right way.
But they might tell you
they don't have bandwidth,
or they might be an
open source project that
runs on volunteers.
In which case, you can
write a code for it.
If you do that, then Google
will give a reward amount
from $500 to $10,000.
To you and/or their
framework maintainers
if they helped you
push it to code.
So we're announcing this for
a couple web applications.
I don't remember the
name of all of them,
so I have to write them don.
So the ones are Angular,
Closure, and Dart, and GWT,
and Go, which are from Google.
And then Django.
[INAUDIBLE] from
the Dojo Foundation,
which are the [INAUDIBLE]
[INAUDIBLE], et cetera.
Ember, Jinja, Werkzeug, and
Flask, JQuery, Knockout,
Struts, and Wicket.
And we're happy to add
more if you tell me
which one I'm missing.
Tell me, if you
want to learn more,
just go
g.co/SecurityPatchRewards.
And that will give
you more information.
AUDIENCE: It will
have that list?
EDUARDO VELA NAVA: It has
that list and way more.
AUDIENCE: Terrific, because
I can't write that fast.
And I won't remember it.
Thank you.
EDUARDO VELA NAVA: No problem.
So if you do that, you will
be able to help yourself
to write simple and secure code.
You will be able to help
millions of fellow developers
to write simple and secure code.
And you will make
everyone happy,
and you will make
yourself happy.
And to finish this
presentation, I just
want to say that it works.
We did this for Google
in a couple cases.
For several type
of vulnerabilities,
for XSS for example.
And it worked.
Some of the products that
were in the top vulnerable
went to [INAUDIBLE]
in a couple years
once they finished
their migration.
That's it.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]